I'm an a journalist with a cause and
I've been so active against oppression
against radical Islamism against the
Muslim Brotherhood and against care
which is the Council on american-islamic
relations that are the I call them
terrorists and suits because these are
the front of the Muslim Brotherhood and
care who groomed Allah and brood
Rashidah and many others and by the way
in 2020 we have more care has been
grooming more than 120 Rashida
Ilhan alike this is the Rubin report and
I'm Dave Rubin quick reminder guys if
you want to see all our videos early and
ad-free join us at Rubin report calm but
more importantly joining me today is a
first-generation American a journalist
and now a candidate for Congress in
Minnesota's fifth District you know the
one currently represented by Ilhan Omar
Dalia Allah Katie welcome to the Rubin
report thank you Dave thanks for having
me here I am very glad to have you here
there's gonna be a lot of stuff that
we're gonna unearth here today but first
let's let's do a little background you
are a first-generation American from
Iraq you you lived under Saddam you have
a really interesting story
so I hand it to you thank you who is
Dalia Dalia is a journalist I grew up in
in a very secular family I grew up in a
family of arts both my parents are
considered pioneers in Iraqi modern
theatre and my uncle so I've been in
like TV business since I was a kid and I
grew up loving arts
I grew up dancing ballet and then in
1988
well yes people say I haven't suffered
personally from the regime
we had everything that we wanted but we
didn't have the freedom and life without
the freedom is it's not worth to live
life without a freedom so so what does
that mean you're living a secular life
your parents are secular and successful
but you're not free what is what does
that actually mean oh we weren't we
didn't just fear some dumb the way his
regime was made you fear for from your
family members or from your relatives or
from your neighbors
you couldn't even joke or mark Saddam or
his family or his governments you'll be
you'll be dead so you had everything but
you can't speak and give an opinion so
for people in the arts this has got to
be EE definitely definitely and this is
yes my family didn't suffer but millions
of Iraqis had suffer and and that's the
question is it just about me or it's
about the the whole country or is
throughout the whole people and that's
one we decided to leave my mother my
little very little brother and myself
even when we decided to leave the
country
we couldn't speak at home we would go
mom and I would go somewhere you know to
a park and park our car and walk just to
plan how are we going to to flee the
country none of my family knew that we
were leaving meaning that if you had
talked at home you think your family
members would have ratted you out or bug
dirt yes because my mom is a very famous
actress and you never know who's
listening to your phone calls who's
who's listening to your conversation
even at home so you're too scared to say
anything go to do anything and we had
friends that
that their houses were bugged and they
disappeared they were executed for
sometimes saying a joke or criticizing
something I mean we couldn't even
criticize the wars that Saddam decided
to to wage we couldn't criticize the way
he the mass murder that he did and
Kurdistan which I'm half Kurdish we
couldn't so this is not the life that
anybody would want to live it's it's
suffocating when you cannot do something
and when you want to make a difference
but but you can't so that's how we
decided to leave and we just each one of
us took two suitcases and that's that's
it we left everything behind yeah I mean
did you just hop on a flight or what do
you have to do to actually get out of an
oppressive regime I thank you for asking
this because in Iraq you can't just
I may have to know in case the
progressives take over in America how
you get out you know you mean so there's
no preservation yeah so if the which
they will never win but if the
Socialists won yeah
you if you need to travel you have to
get a permission to travel and they
would write in your passport like if I'm
going to Athens let's say they would
write she will build to Athens I cannot
go anywhere else if I go somewhere else
and come back I'll be in trouble I'll be
in jail so what happened is I was back
then because I studied state stage
acting and directing so I was going to
perform in Tunisia and Qatar festival so
I have the permission to leave mom had
something I think it was a movie or
something in Cairo so they didn't notice
that because we were in different
delegations that's what they call it
hmm so they didn't notice
so mom because the bait is she had a
baby so and she was supposed to stay
more than one month so she could take
the baby with her and we both left I
after the the festival I run away from
my team from the people I was with and I
sent I gave the Lebanese delegation or
my my two suitcases mm-hmm so nobody
knows what I'm doing because the head of
this delegation told me Dalia somebody
is getting is going from the embassy to
stay here so I had to run away and it
was like I was 20 back then and for me
it was like the longest journey I didn't
know because I left before mom so I
didn't know if mom left or not I was too
scared sitting I was flying to Athens
and from Athens to Beirut because that's
where my aunt is that's where I'm
supposed to reunite with my mother and
my brother
mm-hmm and until because the the
embassies the iraqi embassies during
Saddam's era they were the dissenters of
intelligence so it's so easy for them to
grab you inside the embassy put you in a
box and ship you back back home so
anyways to make this story at the story
short I got my luggage at the airport
from the Lebanese friends and then I sat
down and I was like please God please
God please God until we took off and
when we took off that was the freedom
for my flight to freedom so that's when
you flew so you flew from Lebanon to
America that oh no no sorry no I flew
from Iraq to Tunisia yeah I'm from
Tunisia to Athens Greece and then yes
and because I was Araki I couldn't fly
to the airport because it was
back then it was controlled by the
Syrians so I had to stay eight hours at
Greece and then take another flight to
Larnaca Cyprus and then take a 12-hour
boat to Lebanon to the Christian area
yeah and then I mean it took me like
three days alone not knowing anything
twenty years old but I made it yeah when
I reached there nobody was waiting for
me not my aunt now I had the address
okay take me there I went there it was
during you know the mess in Lebanon so I
reached the apartment it was on the 16th
floor no electricity
I left my suitcases after three days of
non slip I took the stairs sixteenth
floor knocked on the door mom holding my
brother opened the door I just looked at
like my suitcases are down perfect for
two days it's like well it should be a
movie by the way he should be a movie
well that really seems to be only act
one of the movie okay so now now you're
in Lebanon you've reunited with your mom
now what's the plan and I got an offer
from a new ie from TV in Sharjah so we
went to Sharjah and that's when the
Saddam invaded Kuwait so I decided to do
a show to show solidarity with the
Kuwait ease against against Saddam oh so
this is like 91 or no nineteen ninety
ninety okay and then we were contacted
by the Iraqi opposition to work together
to topple Saddam Hussein our part was to
open a radio station called radio of the
free Iraq and bridge area of the Iraqi
opposition so we went to Saudi Arabia
and we were brought
sting from there and that's when I met
Chris Stevens the late ambassador yeah
so can you explain how Chris Stevens so
the ambassador to Libya who obviously
died in the Benghazi attack can you
explain a little bit about your
relationship with him I've met him in
Riyadh I was injured that's who I've met
him in in Riyadh and we became friends
and whenever he comes to Jeddah we would
get together and and he's the one who
who made it happen
because at that time we weren't like
okay we were living in Saudi Arabia
we had residency in UAE because of my
job
but because of our background my mom
myself and I have had a death sentence
issued against me when I was 20 and he's
the one who was convinced and convinced
me that I should go to the US people
like us should be in the u.s. to have a
brighter future and he worked so hard
with the State Department to grant us
political asylum
and it's so sad that today I live here
and he's not there and I can never never
forgive Hillary Clinton for the loss or
for American patriots there and at the
end she said at the end what difference
does it make I've washed her hearings
and it was so sad what else should we
know about Chris Stevens I mean there
were there were three others as well but
he's the name that most people know he
was such a beautiful human being he
learned Arabic and he he has that soft
heart that would
he's very not emotional but he
understands you know and he's the one
who
when when we talk he's the one and and
since then I've been twice - to the US
as a tourist hmm
because back then when we were in Saudi
Arabia we had Saudi passports because we
were doing this high-profile work during
that time and he just was one of the
best people I've ever met he felt for
the people and that's for the past three
years I've been I was doing a show from
DC a weekly show for three years but
it's called us el us Libya
it's about u.s. foreign policy and yours
strategies in North Africa in general in
in Libya particular and the people I've
worked with the Libyans that they
remember him and every Libyan I've met
has told me stories about him and he was
so committed to this country and to the
people the Libyans people and he never
he wasn't scared that this might kill
him yeah what is going on in Libya now
can you do like a quick recap because
it's sort of we did this military action
Benghazi the whole thing and it's like
is it even a functioning country anymore
it's it's not so far and the problem is
because the GNA which is the NGA the
government of GNA government of national
accord is mainly controlled by the
muslim brotherhood and then you have a
general who was here in the United
States as a refugee forever General
after who is so against radical Islamism
and then it's so there is there is still
as a civil war kind of
and the UN as some as we all know it
it's a felt a very failed organization
that couldn't couldn't do anything and
it's just back and forth back and forth
but hopefully meetings are coming with
the Europeans especially that Kurds
reach or could convince the Libyans to
to at least sit together for the average
Libyan though do you think things were
better under Qaddafi it's ever never
ever better under a dictator never never
and I would say that about Iraq as well
yeah all right so let's let's get back
to your story here so when did you move
to the United States so I moved to the
United States in 1993 as soon as I moved
I started working in the media my mother
as well and then I started doing US
media and Arabic and it's so funny
because I was the youngest one well you
know Voice of America and Voice of
America is a federal federal entity so
when I applied for it there were like
400 something and I just went and I did
my test whatever and and then a week
later I was because there was only one
opening and I got it so even I know I'm
like really but the first day I was at
the office all of them were so much
older than I am mm-hmm and they looked
at me like who is she uh-huh but the
first hour I went on air everybody came
it's like now we can say welcome to VOA
and that was a wonderful wonderful
experience don't forget I came here I
speak English so I came to the US
speaking English so it wasn't that hard
for me
to just be there plus I love the culture
I love this country and it's home it's
that's where my heart is
but I don't understand I I thought we're
told all the time that America is an
evil racist patriarchal state that no
dark-skinned immigrant could come to and
be treated fairly especially if they
come from the Middle East the place like
Iraq something like that oh why are you
telling me that's not true and you if
you love this country and work hard you
might be able to make it so you're
telling me I've been here three decades
it was very easy for me to move
somewhere and live if I didn't like it
why would I stay here if I didn't like
it it's one of the most it's one of the
greatest it's it's the greatest country
in the world and is it shocking to you
as someone that lived under what you
lived under had to do everything that
you just laid out to even get here when
you hear all of this endless ridiculous
craziness about how horrible America is
is it just mind-blowing to you it
provokes me that first of all let's talk
about a lot Omar and that's that's very
we were gonna get there there's a lot on
Omar's up here yes because I truly
believe that when you go to a new
country and this country B becomes your
home I mean at least be be grateful that
you you have you live in a country that
you have the right or of every single
American you're no difference than
anybody else you have the right and you
have the duties and and that's how you
should deal with it yet there are
immigrants from different countries I'm
not saying from it or from that they
come here and they don't integrate with
the communities so they still live in a
small area that it's basically they
brought everything from their country
and they're not
willing to participate or a willing to
be part of the of the community and
that's where I feel that organizations
and and should work on on these
communities to build bridges to to make
them feel integrated in schools and that
work place and others I mean can you
believe that someone who lives in for 20
years in a country that can't even speak
the language mm-hmm how you mean it's
not racist to say that maybe you should
speak the language of the country you
live in
or at least try to I mean this is
ridiculous racist no this is this is the
country this is the language of this
country you wanna be a part of this
country part of the communities you want
to be you want to provide you want to
fulfill your duties so you get your
rights I mean this is come on I mean at
least speak the language yeah at least
read the sign all right this is
ridiculous okay so we can link all of
this to Ilhan but before we get
specifically into her just tell me a
little bit about what your general
political philosophy is because now that
you're running for Congress obviously
that's it can't just be about I'm
against Ilhan no well is that that but
just tell me a little bit about your own
sort of political beliefs a question
that I've been asked so many times
thinking that all immigrants and there
they should be Democrats I'm a
conservative person I have conservative
principles since I came here so being a
journalist I know exactly what these two
political parties are so it's easy for
me I mean to be conservative and to be a
Republican and that's what I've been
since since I
I think here I truly believe that
decency should be back in our political
arena and our lives will we've lost it
we've lost that and this is this is so
bad I mean the hatred that we see now
this was never the narrative in the
United States yes we disagree but we
don't hate in each other
I don't hate somebody because he's a
Democrat maybe I would never marry a
Democrat would be fighting all the time
yeah but an honest politician yeah
exactly but you know what it's sad that
you see in 2020 that hatred there the
toxic narratives coming from the far
left
I wouldn't say coming from the Democrat
in general the the far left and the
progressive that are trying to destroy
this country people don't want this this
country to be a socialist country people
don't want to live in Cuba people don't
want to live in Venezuela people don't
want to live in these countries or even
Russia for this matter so we have people
that are praising these other countries
I mean if you praise it and you like it
so much
go be a senator there yeah or a
congresswoman right well that's what I
always say nobody ever leaves come here
nobody's leaving we're not stopping
people from leaving but they never leave
so was it seeing what was happening with
the with the far left progressives and
the Socialists is that really what drove
you to get into politics or was it
specifically about Ilhan and then we'll
talk more about her
well being a journalist and I've been
doing it for a long time and I do
foreign affairs and I cover the whole
world and covering wars
conflict zones Human Rights crisis al
terrorist attacks all over the world
especially in Europe I've been there
done that so I know what kind of outcome
would come from a narrative like like
this the oppression the the hatred the
anti-semitism and I think Alan Omar made
the biggest mistake of her life it was
right when she got elected and she
didn't wait for long to bring out all
the ugliness yeah well it was almost
like day one she suddenly flipped on all
of these things even though a lot of us
could see it beforehand obviously yeah
but I'm being there so as a journalist
and I'm I'm very active I'm an a
journalist with a cause and I've been so
active against oppression against
radical Islamism against the Muslim
Brotherhood and against care which is
the Council on american-islamic
relations that are the I call them
terrorists in suits because these are
the front of the Muslim Brotherhood and
care who groomed Allah and brood
Rashidah and many others and by the way
in 2020 we have more care has been
grooming more than 120 Rashida al Han
alike that we were going to see that so
what happened with Al Han that of course
I saw a couple of her interviews she's
always on in Jazeera with Maggie
Hosseini
Hasani Madison that I can't stand
because of his views of course and he's
so pro Muslim Brotherhood so I told my
producers I want to interview her
we were so ignored and I kept tweeting
to her like okay now we're a Muslim to a
Muslim woman to a woman and form a
refugee to a former refugee
anyways I was ignored on and definitely
she would not give me an interview so I
decided you know what because I was
doing my research on Muslim Brotherhood
and on all this because that's what I
write about when I'm not on TV I decided
I said you know I don't want her
interview I'm going to her district mmm
and I went to her district and I spoke
to the people and I was going back and
forth back and forth spending time there
and even sometimes on Twitter I would
say I'm going to be in this place from
this time to it
come and meet me journalists and others
so I had all this research about this
district way before anything else and
then six months ago I decided to move
there and I started thinking that if I
run I would be the best the only
candidate that could beat her because of
my background I'm immune to her brand of
identity politics so I can push straight
for the important issues and important
discussions and I'm not a shy person at
all and I could say you are one two
three
why did you meet turkish President
Erdogan before you were elected what
promises did you did you give him why
you refused to acknowledge the the
Turkish ethnic cleansing against the
Armenians
why were you outraged because President
Trump decided to take justice to custom
Soleimani why are you close to the
Muslim Brotherhood how much money have
you been getting from care through or
through care from Qatar and from the
godfather of the Muslim Brotherhood I
could do what no other candidates could
basically because if you
tell her this you're white supremacists
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're a time I
slept she cannot accuse me of that well
she can't accuse you of it and I'm sure
she will accuse you of it it's not very
credible yeah because I grew up and
probably I know more about religion than
she does most likely yeah do you sense
she's using religion as a shield
of course she's using everything and she
has this victim cards that she throws at
you oh I was five I have PTSD I was five
years old and no girls should live at
war because any war and everywhere
around the globe it's because of the
United States so what can you talk a
little bit about the tactics so you
mentioned this Muslim Brotherhood Care
Connection we mentioned we talked
briefly before we started about Brigitte
Gabriel who's really been laying this
thing out for years what the plan is to
infiltrate you're now saying there's
over 100 candidates that are being
groomed by them but I think one of the
tactics which you sort of hit on is this
constant desire to make everything feel
crazy all the time and it almost seems
like every time to leave in a way
Rasheed is who he is almost worse than
Ilhan in this way that everything she
says seems to be designed to make
maximum chaos and and is that really
part of what they do that's the main
thing that they do and that's how they
get support I mean in HoN Omar or Rashid
Utley let me talk about each one because
they have similar tactics but on
different issues like Al Han Omar when
she keeps feeding or tweeting or saying
the same narrative over and over and
over that I represent every Muslim in
the country first she's supposed to
represent the fifth District she's
supposed to serve the fig the fifth
District
and she's done zero nada nothing so when
she goes and tells all the Muslims that
the Americans haters the white people
haters and there are so entire Islamists
and there that the islamaphobe that the
term that was invented by care yeah so
we've talked about this a bunch of the
show but can you explain why the term
specifically Islamophobe was invented
and why it's such a confusing term to
counterpart the anti-semitism so it's
easier to say Islamophobe so you could
okay if you are an Islamophobe that's
why you're with with others that hate
all the Muslims in the United States
well number one if they hated all the
Muslims I've been here three decades as
an adult yeah how come nobody hated me
well I'm sure this is a very different
people probably hating for your ideas
now Ilhan is probably not thrilled with
you I doubt that but even after 9/11
like nine twelve I have never felt
threatened because I was a Muslim I'm an
American regardless of Ovie's I don't
use this and the problem is or I'm
forced to use a Muslim former refugee
immigrants just to the identity politics
that she uses and I stated it once on
Twitter that was picked up by everybody
because she said I am a job which is
that is not the right to job that she
claims to and I've spoken to several
American Somalis that this is not the
Muslims a job I mean she wears the hijab
regard based on the people that she's
meeting she's meeting Muslims she would
cover but her job as a ninja you cannot
show your chest you cannot show your
hands it's it's it's all it's Muslims
know that right
also plenty of the policies that she's
for would not be policies that if you
were a strict Muslim you would be for
like help abortion is a right yes well
I'm sorry abortion is health care
exactly okay and it's human rights as
well so but the problem with the people
in the district that they don't follow
what she does in DC on a daily basis
they don't know that she missed half
half of the votes that anyone else in
the house
she doesn't vote for the district you
know when she votes when it comes to
foreign policies that's why her votes
and can you believe that she voted
against ending aids to to someone at
Somalia and then she went outside
ten minutes later giving a press
conference saying oh we did it I mean
this woman is filled with lies and again
her worst mistake that she didn't give
me the interview that what made me go
back and forth and that what made me
decide that I am gonna cross the line
between being a journalist to a
politician so what are some of the other
tactics that they use besides the just
general they're they want to cause chaos
all the time and seem to always
everything they say seems to be designed
to deepen that divide what else what
else are they doing the free handouts
that it on reality doesn't work
how could you give free health care to
everybody it doesn't work this way I
mean where would they get the money from
how could you forgive all the student
loans what would they do for people that
already pay their loans
yeah we're not getting anything back
yeah yeah know how I mean all these
hands out and and like free this and
free this and everybody is gonna have a
free house and it's gonna have a friend
this is ridiculous we are not in China
and even in China they don't do that
that's right so but can you explain a
little bit more how the Islamists and
and care and Muslim Brotherhood how they
use the progressives like it's like
because this is what I think a lot of
people a lot of people see this match
made in hell you're supposed to be
progressive but all these other values
are completely anti progressive but I
don't think people really understand
them how this thing fully ties together
because the progressive don't have minds
their right mind the Muslim Brotherhood
is using the far left and the
progressive for their own agendas
they're not doing it for the sake of the
far left or the sake of progressive no
they are using them big time yeah and do
you think Bernie just doesn't get it he
just doesn't see it or he's so deep down
the socialist ladder that he feels he
has more in common with Islamists then
than with an American the average
American something like that
I mean supportive or the BDS what do you
expect I mean if you're an American and
if you are worried about what's
happening in that region in general you
want to be close and you want to defend
your closest allies which at this point
is Israel now more countries are coming
like Saudi Arabia UAE Egypt
who's going to counter Iran's influence
in the region nobody and I cannot
understand why someone like Bernie that
does not care about our allies I mean
imagine him being a president what's
gonna happen oh my god we'll have
Iranian influence all over the place
forget about something called peace in
the Middle East and we'll have Wars in
the middle and the Middle East between
our ex allies and our new allies is is
that the biggest weakness of what
progressives are
that it also it all kind of sounds good
it sounds good out were for Pete right
Bernie I'm for peace we're gonna sit
down with everybody how how I mean when
President Trump went to nor met with the
North Korean leader everybody went crazy
everybody inclusive including the the
Democrats the far left everybody went
crazy okay he's sitting and talking and
having dialogue for peace
so always for them it's okay for us it's
a no-no so what else are you gonna do in
Minnesota's fifth District to supplant
Aloha nomer before that I am planning
and I will represent every every voter
in this district and not even a voter
every resident of the fifth District
because I am running to represent them
I'm planning to introduce Minneapolis
and the fifth District to DC not bring
DC to Minneapolis and to that district
she felt to do anything for them and for
me this is I mean she's supposed to be a
public servant a public servant means
that you serve your constituents and
that's what I'm planning to do um I will
represent every resident of the fifth
District regardless of color ethnicity
faith and political affiliation what do
you think the Somali community thinks of
hers they are seriously they are sick
and tired of her scandals of her outside
influences of her narrative that she is
tarnishing every the repetition of every
Muslim every American Muslim and they
know it now and they I mean I speak to I
mean to in the district I speak to
somebody's and I speak to Muslims and
they the majority agreed there
she tarnished their reputation people
there are not waiting just for handouts
these are hard workers the and all that
they want is to have better lives to
send their kids to better school to have
a safe district you mean the same thing
as every other American exactly exactly
we don't need names we are all Americans
I don't when I when I travel when people
ask me Oh were you from I don't say I'm
an American from I am an American period
and that's the values that I have are
the American values and the people I
love are the Americans does it mean that
I hate Iraq it's always my that's what I
was born and these are my extended
families but when it comes to my heart
my heart is here that's why I've been
living here for 30 years and I'm not
planning to go anywhere and that's why I
have only one passport which is the US
passport will you come on stage with me
I have a show in Minneapolis for my book
tour I'm gonna bring you on stage if you
change your mind I'll sue you know it's
it's been recorded all right I'll get
you the date but I'll be in Minneapolis
around the may 10th or so I would be
honored yeah
to do so that I would be honored I will
not be happy with I'll invite her too
though if she's watching right now she's
welcome to come on stage with both of us
well I've been it's just I've been
inviting you for there you go yeah you
can talk to the camera
a cup of coffee forever so I think maybe
we should have coffee in the
neighborhood that you don't live there
anymore because you moved to DC so I'm
in Minneapolis where is she she's in DC
it yeah can you talk a little bit about
some of the other scandals related to
her because there's there's a lot of
weird stuff out there and for the last
two years it was only these very I don't
want to say very far right it was
seemingly far-right outlets I don't even
want to say that they were outlets on
the right that are ignored by mainstream
that were saying there was this weird
thing with her and her brother and
passports and this whole thing can you
kind of get me up to speed on what we
know I mean usually
I don't speak about it but it's I mean
there are investigations for about so
many things like three four for me one
is many yeah and especially about the
immigration fraud because apparently
based on a community leader and in the
Somali community came out and including
pictures and and let me tell you what
happened
and then hopefully the investigation
would lead to because she would not
never talk about it and it's like oh
this is so appalling yeah well she's
under investigation right now
definitely immigration definitely yeah
apparently she had a brother who lived
in the United States came down in London
and according to her close friends that
went on the record saying that because
her brother was gay so she decided to
bring him to the u.s. being inside the
within the Somali community so maybe
he'll get killed this is the one who who
defends the LGBT community yet she wants
to cure her brother by being in this
community so he came but as a British
citizen he cannot live here so basically
they got married and to give him well
it's not like for any other reasons I
mean it's it's it's committing an
immigration fraud and that's how he got
his citizenship she brought him to cure
him and basically she used to say
according to her friends and to the
people that went on the record saying
that he's been around the wrong crowd in
England so it's better for him to come
here and be around us right okay so
putting aside the part about the gay
brother and the keyring which is bad
enough in
itself especially by her own progressive
ideals where she's supposed to be for
gay people but but that's not criminal
in and of itself marrying your brother
for the purposes of getting an
immigration immigration status is
immigration fraud and this is under
investigation right now yes do you think
it's bizarre the way the mainstream
media seems to be covering this up or is
that just sort of congruent with
everything else they I think we got used
to the mainstream media sadly but we got
used to it
have we ever heard anything about
anybody about progressive about a
Democrat yeah it's always about the us
the Conservatives the Republicans it's
always about us what about all the
scandals that were around a large
percentage of the Democrats
it's those under the radar and they
would even if they mention it they would
mention it in and in times that are not
very popular so and and then that's it
and that's well instead the New York
Times writes a piece about the new hip
artist in town hunter Biden yeah you saw
that one in The Times yeah the new hot
artist in town I'm pretty sure Donald
Trump jr. wouldn't get the same coverage
there are times up no not even not Trump
not his kids not his children does it
feel in a weird way so for someone that
that was a journalist under a
dictatorship does that or came from a
country that was a dictatorship when you
see the way our media behaves right now
similar similar exactly exactly similar
I mean having they always try to defend
all the mainstream media they pretend to
defend the First Amendment but what
they're doing is so anti the First
Amendment freedom of speech is the most
important thing there are just doing and
I know it I
what the narrative of the progressives
and of Ilhan oh of Rasheeda what they
bring of sieved the consequences of the
hatred I've seen the consequences of
oppression and of division I ran away
from it and I was fighting it for 31
years and I am as an American citizen
would stand against it from now I was
standing against it and I will until the
day I die
no does anything about the machine that
you're going up against scare you in any
way just I mean at the most human level
I mean I know you've been through worse
in a lot of ways but I'll tell you it's
a big it's a huge machine especially
when it comes to radical Muslims and to
the Muslim Brotherhood and to the people
behind the Muslim Brotherhood please
know if you hear or if you read that I
committed suicide I'm not suicidal
I'm very happy and so look for them
because definitely I'm not we've seen
suicides here and there lately and the
the Muslim Brotherhood is a terrorist
group and the first thing would be my
priority when I get elected in November
that I will make sure the Muslim
Brotherhood would be designated as a
terrorist group such as several
countries Egypt that's where the Muslim
Brotherhood was formed yeah
Egypt considerate and other countries in
the region considered a terrorist group
and we should we should too - I'm not
scaring I'm not trying to scare people
but we shouldn't be afraid of name and
calling things with their real names
and that's not Islamic that's not anti
that's being anti terrorism and entire
radicalism and if I don't stand against
it who else I know that I'm from them
yeah so as a conservative and as
a trump supporter I thought Trump was
supposed to hate Muslims doesn't he hate
Muslims doesn't he hate immigrants
doesn't he hate brown people
that's what mainstream media is telling
us exactly look what I'm doing and where
where I'm running and most of my friends
when I like most of them are Republicans
and our conservatives that we've been
friends forever and I've been doing some
work with other think tanks and
especially when it comes to Islamism and
the radical Islamism and I speak to
people even to Muslims and I speak to
the Somalis in my district telling them
that she is not helping you if you think
that she's helping you she is not and
they agree because she has done nothing
for them I mean she's for open borders
do we especially now with the with the
coronavirus do we what kind of as a
country that doesn't control its borders
what kind of a country that is what do
you think about putting Ilhan
specifically so I just Pete a
first-generation immigrant that comes to
America that sort of has the gall to
then just try to undermine everything
she's doing it for herself she's
polishing her international profile I
mean she was more concerned to be on the
cover of Vogue than doing anything for
her constituents she is I mean I wonder
why is she sitting on the Foreign
Affairs of the House Foreign Affairs
Committee what does she know other than
the hatred to Israel she knows some
people did something exactly that one
yeah and I sent her a message from
seatback when I spoke that you know what
some people are going to do something
that will make you a one-term
congressman so her endless hatred of
Israel you just spoke at AIPAC you gave
what I thought was a pretty incredible
speech and one of the things you really
focused on actually was what's happening
to the Christians in the Middle
least which is sort of a forgotten piece
of the whole thing I guess can you talk
a little bit about just generally her
obsession with Israel but then more just
what's happening with the Christians in
the Middle East and everything else well
let's talk about the BDS that she
introduced to the house
I mean her hatred to to not only Israel
to all the Jews in the United States and
to every American that doesn't follow
her narrative or that supports Israel
there is a a very big food company in
our district in Minneapolis called
General Mills General Mills does
business with Israel and they make
Cheerios exactly and that company is
employing more than 10 10,000 people
from our district because of her hatred
or her obsession with Israel she is
willing to lose the jobs I mean to make
the people of her district lose the jobs
I mean what what does it take ten jobs
10,000 jobs she does not care she wants
to satisfy her hatred to the Jews to the
Americans that support Israel and to
Israel itself one mistake she did when
if you remember when she and Rasheeda
were invited by Mustafa which is a
terrorist group to visit Gaza and thank
God the Israelis decided that this is
not the the the good idea because
Rashida claimed in the name of the
government she would go to Gaza to bash
Israel and best-best Jews right again
the only place in the Middle East that
has any of the seemingly progressive
values that made
a chair pretty sure Hamas not very
progressive right Hamas well define
progressive when it comes to bombings I
know when it comes to missile attacks
although before that Ilhan tweeted the
Palestinians in the Congress have spoken
since when we have Palestinians in our
Congress she didn't even bother to say
the Americans from Palestinian origins
know that Palestinians in Congress which
made me like do we have Palestinians in
the Congress I thought just we're
supposed to have Americans in our
Congress yeah the best ones you remember
when Talib tweeted the thing about being
the first Palestinian in Congress and
then Justin Amash yeah who's the
libertarian in Michigan said oh well
actually my father's from Palestinian
descent I just don't make a big deal
about it exactly I'm American exactly
exactly um although I do feel for the
Palestinian people because I truly
believe that they are held hostages
between Hamas the terrorist group
between the corruption of the
Palestinian authorities and the
corruption of Fatah and it's time for
them and they've tried the drug but
they've tried especially in Gaza where
Hamas rules everything you know what
they do Hamas they would bring the truck
in the middle of a residential area to
launch missiles and leave a minute later
when Israel countered the attack who
would die of course of course them the
Palestinian people are sick and tired of
this they deserve and they want to live
in prosperity and that's what then you
plan that president Trump offered and of
course it was rejected by the
Palestinian Authority and everybody else
I mean so Trump got so Trump got
basically
Plus countries if not more onboard this
he basically got Israel onboard it but
it was basically it was pretty much
Hamas the Palestinian Authority Ilhan
and and I don't know and a couple others
that that were against it because it's
based on reality it's not like we've
been doing the same you know that the
the US has been doing the same plan and
keeps repeating it over and over and
over expecting to have a different
outcome I mean that's so foolish because
if you have this plan didn't work it
hasn't worked for decades so bring
something else and what's great about
this plan I mean it it gives the
Palestinian people the opportunity to
prosper and believe me if they're not
hungry if they have more job
opportunities that's what they want they
don't want to wipe Israel from the face
well Hamas does Rashidah does el Han and
Bernie definitely these people do you
think they enjoy their lives no do you
know how all these Palestinian leaders
are living their living la vida loca
they have the best houses the best cars
they have Abbas has quite a castle over
there exactly and on our army as well
all of them and the people are begging
for for jobs and this would work
especially now more than ever their Arab
countries and Muslim countries are ready
to normalize the relations and ties with
Israel do you see that as like a
mind-blowing thing that you've got all
these Arab countries now that are
starting to do have different bilateral
relations with Israel and yet we have
American Congress people who are further
who are more against it than Arab
countries who've technically been at war
with Israel well Russia to free to move
to Gaza and and fight fight there and el
Han could feel free to go
katar maybe or turkey with the Godfather
of the Muslim Brotherhood just don't
spread your toxic rhetoric between us
because nobody's gonna nobody's gonna
stand this and especially the
consequences of what they are doing
yeah all right so what else you gonna do
for the good people of Minnesota's fifth
District I think we've we've laid out
why they shouldn't vote for Ilhan what
else are you gonna do for these people
uh a lot um my issue number one is
immigration reform and that's not anti
Muslims or entire immigrants and that's
what President Trump is doing um um I'm
the best candidate to defeat her and to
help the administration to implement all
these laws because if I go talk to an
immigrant or to an illegal immigrant and
I tell him I'll tell her that you know
what there are reforms are coming and
that doesn't mean that you'll be thrown
out it's just we have to be fair for the
people that came here legally we have to
be fair for the people that waited for
years years and years in order for them
to get their Asylum will work on on on
the immigration definitely reform I am a
hundred percent supporter of their wall
and especially now with everything that
is happening and if you think just we're
just trying to to stop certain people
from entering no terrorists could go
easily to Mexico or to other places and
cross our borders that's number two
safety is extremely important in our
district
Ilhan Omar and I hate to keep bring her
her but and she calls for less police
presence in in our district
while crime rate is going up sky high
mm-hmm
we can improve their security throughout
a legislation that would provide more
funds we can use all these new
technologies instead of just putting
people on the street security
technologies are the best there are
programs that could tell you in in this
area where a gun was fired right there
live we can do a lot we can support the
people of this district health care we I
could promise that I would work with the
administration but you have the right to
choose your healthcare provider I'm not
just giving handouts we could push for
several companies that provide health
care to their employees the countries
that the companies that are treating the
employees as independent contractors we
can do something if you work certain
hours for this company you're no more
independent contract so we can work with
these companies to prove to provide
healthcare and it's the choice of the
person I don't need to be forced to go
to doctor a not to dr. B I don't need to
be forced to go to hospital C in a
hospital D it's my it's it's it's it's
my choice individual choice and
competition er you're a real radical
well yeah and small businesses in our
district is suffering a lot and we need
to to give the freedom of all the choice
of being an employee of being a business
owner the district could Lou could use a
lot
and it's a beautiful I fell in love with
it from day one that I arrived at in
Minneapolis
it's such a beautiful place that
beautiful people and it could I mean
Minneapolis should be just like LA a
metropolitan area that old tourists from
all over the world would want to come
and see it has all the ingredients we
need to build more the infrastructure of
this city and it will be on the map like
Florida New York DC LA it should be on
the tourism map maybe not with now with
the coronavirus and stuff which by the
way all the oh the far left is
criticizing the government and the
administration President Bush for not
doing anything
excuse me I mean asking for 2.6 billion
and I'm not sure it's 2 for 2 point 5 or
6 to to support the research and and 2
to enhance all the medical research and
and medicine that's not good
why not good I mean well the orange man
did it so yeah this is ridiculous and I
think I think it's sad I mean a long
time ago the Democratic Party used to be
a decent party because it's all about
two parties I'm willing and that's what
I'm going to do for my district to build
new coalition to reach not to the other
eye on to the last aisle on this planet
if that what it takes to provide the
services that my constituents do I don't
insult Democrats I don't keep insulting
them like she keeps insulting the
Republicans even though she had
Republicans in our district so I'm
willing to build much bigger coalition's
I'm willing and I will do everything
bipartisan and that's
the country should I mean it's politics
101 I have a feeling I'm looking at the
next congresswoman from Minnesota's
fifth district you are and as long as
schedules lined up I'm bringing you
onstage in Minneapolis in May I wish I
could remember the date offhand but
we're gonna link to the event right down
below so people can join us and for more
on Dalia go to Dalia for congress.com if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell